the team we wanted to really see in the
playoffs because of who they've been the
last few years is the kansas city chiefs
and you know for a little while you're
like whoa what what's going on here
seven nothing
they're down and then they just explode
right five consecutive touchdowns they
score three touchdowns right or
in the last three minutes of the first
half
we're going to go to our next guest who
was a part of those teams played for
andy reid was an all-pro tackle super
bowl champion
brother to uh my my uh co-worker there
at sirius xm radio on the pac-12 mr jeff
schwartz so welcome to the show mitchell
schwartz what's up [ __ ] how are we
doing
i'm doing good thanks for having me on
you bet man um
i told everybody to kind of tamper their
their expectations a little bit because
the chiefs were playing the steelers
right it was it wasn't uh a team that i
think a lot of people thought would give
them a lot of trouble what was your
biggest takeaway from from their
performance uh and what do you expect uh
expect this week
so weirdly enough my biggest takeaway
was a little bit of worry because
if we see that first like quarter
quarter and a half where you have you
know five drives two turnovers one of
them leading to points for the other
team against this buffalo team you know
you could be down three touchdowns
pretty quickly so i think that
inconsistency that we've seen throughout
the season is still there a little bit
but the optimism of as you said those
five or six touchdown drives in a row
looking like the chiefs of old uh i know
that's got to choose kingdom pretty
excited so hopefully they're able to you
know ride that into this game and start
fast and i think i mean for them the
whole season it's been kind of the
self-inflicted stuff so
false starts holdings drop passes kind
of weird things happening where
leading to turnovers or bad drives and
so if they're able to get a
grip on that you know this is a team and
an offense especially that is very tough
to stop
you spent a majority of your time there
in in kansas city in fact some of the
most successful right with the super
bowl victory
in miami and uh you've seen firsthand
how andy reid eric b enemy how they game
plan how they prepare
what do you think um they're reiterating
in those meetings
in practice sessions and walk-throughs
everything that that they have to get
right this week and an understanding
that buffalo is going to come with
everything they've got
yeah it's a lot of accountability and uh
eric the enemy is awesome with holding
everyone accountable making sure they're
doing their part because you know if
you're doing your thing especially as an
offensive lineman that means pac can do
his that means you know clyde or you
know jerick now the running back like
they can do their thing and so having
that accountability and responsibility
to your teammates to do the right thing
is huge and if you're a receiver you
know you've got the responsibility to
catch the ball to you know not make sure
that it gets tipped into the air someone
can pick it and so you know eb is big on
all that uh accountability and holding
guys to their responsibility i think the
biggest thing
is just getting back to practice itself
and make making sure you're practicing
fast practicing crisp you know coach
reed does not like when the ball's on
the ground in practice because that
means usually something went wrong
whether it's an incompletion or a fumble
especially so going through the week of
practice
making sure you got the right attitude
the right effort and then
not having the ball in the ground as i'm
sure you heard that throughout your
career too but
that's one of the indicators the coaches
look at to see how chris practices
we're talking to mitchell schwartz
former all pro offensive tackle
for the kansas city chief super bowl
champion
uh and uh palisades uh
high school graduate i think you were a
dolphin weren't you
i was yeah look at that look at that all
right um
playing in arrowhead okay now i have a
a different experience playing in
arrowhead with all my years with the
chargers and having to go there and how
difficult a place it is
tell us how important home field
advantage is the fact that patrick
mahomes has yet to have to go on the
road to play a playoff game
how big a deal it is to be home in front
of those fans in that stadium
well it's a big deal for a couple of
reasons you know as you're leading to
for the opposing offense it's just
incredibly difficult to have a clean
operation because you know steve's
magnolia's defense he's got all these
blitz schemes and landing lining up guys
in different spots and he's playing
three or four safeties and be
interchangeable and so you know josh
allen's gonna get up to the line of
scrimmage he's gonna be trying to figure
out who's blitzing and he's gonna have
to you know run up to the line of
scrimmage basically run up to both
tackles tell them the protection call
and get that done and you're wasting
pressure seconds and um it makes it more
difficult things are a little bit more
strained and it just makes the operation
a little bit more challenging and then
you know offensively we get a boost from
you know our defense has a great drive
it's a threat now they're excited we get
a nice
turn you know we feel that energy on
offense as we take the field and so it's
more than just you know affecting the
other team's offense it's this energy
this excitement level and
it's really special you know one of my
favorite moments from a couple years ago
from the super bowl run was actually
after the afc championship game that we
won you know in a weird way i felt like
that one was a little bit more special
than
post game of the super bowl because it
was at arrowhead it was all our fans it
was all the people that have been
cheering us on cheering us on for
forever more like an intimate setting
and getting to share that moment with
them so it is a little bon between you
know player and uh fan and
as you said and well tested it's a
pretty tough play place to play for an
opposing quarterback yeah it's extremely
difficult you've talked about that that
noise factor and what it's going to be
for josh allen now
all three teams left in the afc uh
outside of the chiefs
have all beat the chiefs this year and
it's the playoffs i don't put a lot of
weight into that but all three of these
teams have
and know what it's like to beat this
team regardless of whether it was early
in the season cincinnati beat them late
in the season when when the chiefs
definitely needed to win
so what what does that have going into
this game in terms of confidence for one
team or lack of confidence with another
or is it just a wash it's playoff time
you throw out the records and let's go
it's a little bit above i do think there
is a mental component to
knowing that you've stood toe to toe and
beat that team until you look at the
cincinnati game that was the most recent
so you can say those teams are probably
the most similar to it to where they
currently are right now you know the
buffalo game was week four or five the
chiefs were missing a bunch of guys they
didn't have melvin ingram at the time he
was on pittsburgh and so you're looking
at it and you're saying well it's not
quite the same matchup but buffalo's
coming to town they're not afraid
they're thinking all right we already
beat them before we can do it again we
just came off a great game and so it is
strange to be the only team left who
hasn't beaten any of the other three
teams during that season and i do think
there is that little mental component so
it's something that uh
makes it as well-rounded of you know a
four teams that we've seen in the afc
playoffs in a long time we go to these
offensive and defensive coordinators in
the scheme right that's a big word
that's used in every broadcast and in
report the scheme that this defensive
coordinator brings or this offensive
coordinator brings to the table steve
spagnola brings a a blitzing
pressure
uh
you know fueled kind of defense now in
in their last loss at cincinnati in a
game where
joe burrow was just begging for
one-on-one match-ups with the likes of
jamar chase and and uh t higgins steve
spagnola kept giving it to him and kept
getting burnt
do you think there was a time in in the
week leading up to that denver game the
final game of the year where where andy
reid you know pulled his defensive
coordinator aside and said hey you know
you
your ego has to be removed from this we
have to do what's best for this team and
scheme is one thing winning the football
game is what is most important
you know i feel like they have those
conversations during the week and
i feel like they come out of it trusting
each other and so they go into the game
with the game plan and knowing hey if
we're in this situation we're going to
call that you know i think coach reed's
on the headset so he can know the play
call that spags was thrown in and so if
he
gets that cover zero call and it's
really the wrong one i'm sure there's a
line of communication to possibly
overrule it
but i would say that that aggressive
attacking mentality is what has led to
success for the defense and so it's
buying into
yeah we're going to put it out there and
you guys got to beat us one-on-one but
we think we can get home we think we can
beat you one-on-one and so there's
probably a little bit of that hey you
know this is just not the right
situation for it but as snags described
a couple days after you know he was
trying to push since he had a field goal
range they're right on the edge of i
think it was the 40 or the 45 and the
ads third and 27 but he's almost playing
that like a fourth and five because he
doesn't want them to throw a quick slant
and get into field goal range and be
able to kick it so i think that on the
whole i mean we've seen
coach reid has brought in spags a couple
times about his career to be his
coordinator clearly he trusts and
you know coach reed has definitely got
that attacking mentality as well we see
that on offense and so i think it
complements
the other side very well and i think
they both uh see the game in the same
way that
if you're not attacking you know that's
when things happen and there are you
know smarter play calls to be had in
certain situations but i think on the
whole that mentality is going to be a
positive for them yeah i agree i agree
that's mitchell schwartz everybody all
pro uh tackle for the kansas city chiefs
uh super bowl champion thanks for taking
some time with us today man looking
forward to this football game
yeah i appreciate it it's going to be a
good one
all right everybody mitchell schwartz
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here